the chair recognizes mr. white House
Counsel ruff Thank You mr. chief justice
how's the sound system today okay mr.
Chief Justice managers for the house
ladies and gentlemen of the Senate I
can't resist beginning following the
lead of my colleagues across the well
here by telling you that my name is
Charles ruff and I'm from the District
of Columbia and we don't have a vote in
the Congress of the United States I
truly did not intend to begin quite this
way but I I must I don't think there is
a court in the land where a prosecutor
would be able to stand up for one third
of his a lot of time speak in general
terms about the what the people are
entitled to and what the rule of law
stands for as important as all event may
be and sit down and turn to the
defendants counsel and ask that defense
counsel go forward reserving two hours
for rebuttal
I recognize that procedural niceties
have not necessarily characterized the
way this trial has gone forward but I do
believe and this is the only time today
I will say this I promise that kind of
prosecutorial gambit is symptomatic of
what we have seen before in these last
week's wanting to win too much
now that said let me begin where I went
intended to begin we are taking the last
steps along a path that for most of us
has seemed to be unending indeed some of
us may have a sense that we've gone well
beyond Yogi Berra land - deja vu all
over again and all over again and all
over again I thought long and hard as I
thought about what I was going to say
today how I could be of most help to you
as you make this momentous decision that
will soon be entrusted to you I
momentarily considered whether the
answer to that question was simply to
yield back my time
but I weighed that against the special
pleasure of stretching out our last
hours with you
or as Ernie Banks would have said it's
such a nice day let's play too but
cursed as I am with loyally instincts I
decided to compromise I promised you as
much brevity as I can manage even if not
much wit while making a few final points
I think you need to carry with you as
you go into your deliberation
now you have heard the manager's vision
or at least some part of it their vision
of the process we've been engaged in and
the lessons we've learned and what it
will look like at the end of our journey
I respect them as elected
representatives of their people and as
worthy adversaries but I believe their
vision to be too dark a vision too
little attuned to the needs of the
people too little sensitive to the needs
of our democracy I believe it to be a
vision more focused on retribution more
designed to achieve partisan ends more
uncaring about the future we face
together our vision I think is quite
different but it is not naive we know
the pain the president has caused our
society and his family and his friends
but we know too how much the president
has done for this country and more
importantly we know that our primary
obligation the duty we all have is to
preserve that which the founders gave us
and we can best fulfill that duty by
carefully traveling the path that they
laid out for us now you've heard many
speeches over the past few weeks about
high crimes and misdemeanors as I look
back on the arguments and the counter
arguments seems to me that really very
little can be gained by repeating them
for when all is said and done what they
mean is this
the framers chose stability they made
impeachment and removal constitutional
recourses of last resort a question that
the managers appear to have asked I am
unable to tell you what they will ask
today is whether perjury or obstruction
of justice in the abstract are in P
chable offenses that is not the question
you must answer nor must you assume as
the managers appear to that because
judges are removed for having committed
perjury a president must be removed as
well that is not what the law the rule
of law requires the rule of law and
even-handed justice is something more
than a simple syllogism you must decide
whether on these facts arising out of
these circumstances this president has
so endangered the state that we can no
longer countenance is remaining in
office now I think in their hearts the
managers do not truly disagree whatever
tidbits they've been able to glean from
the historical record or more modern
scholarship they cannot in the end avoid
the conclusion that removal of the
president is not something that the
framers took lightly indeed two of their
own witnesses in the Judiciary Committee
professor Van Alstyne and judge Wiggins
tried to make it clear to them that even
if they were to find that the offenses
described in the independent counsels
referral had been committed another
decision had to be made and that
decision was whether in the interest of
society the president should be
impeached as Professor Van Alstyne put
it in words that I admit are
unflattering to my client but
nonetheless make the point in my own
opinion he said I regard if the
president did that which the special
counsels report declared are crimes of
such a low order that it would unduly
flatter the president by submitting him
to trial
in the Senate I would not bother to do
it now I read that statement to you not
obviously because the professor and I on
the same side of the political divide
are the same view of the president's
conduct but because it is important I
think to understand as I fear the
managers do not that the framers full
well understood what they were doing
when they drafted the impeachment
provisions of the Constitution they
consciously chose not to make all
misconduct by the president of basis for
removal they chose instead only that
conduct that they viewed as most serious
as most dangerous to our system of
government as I said I think in their
hearts the managers recognize the force
of this but they've argued to you that
perjury and obstruction really should be
treated as the equivalent of treason and
bribery in the danger that they pose to
our society they've offered on this much
rhetoric and a few substantive arguments
and I want to look at just a few of
these arguments as they were advanced in
the managers opening and not really
addressed since then first and
historical argument that Blackstone in
his commentaries listed bribery and
Burge perjury and obstruction of justice
under the same heading of offenses
against public justice second a sort of
modern statutory equivalent of that
argument that under the sentencing
guidelines we actually treat perjury
more severely than we do bribery and
third and this is the theme you've heard
throughout these proceedings what I'll
call the system of Justice argument that
the president's conduct if he is not
removed will somehow subvert enforcement
of our civil rights laws but all these
arguments are mere subterfuge offered
because the managers knew that to make
any plausible case for removal they must
bring these articles within the very
small circle of offenses that the
framers believed were truly dangerous to
the state
first black stone it's true that the
commentaries rate per jury is among 21
offences against public justice notably
however black stone ranks the 21 in
order of seriousness or as he puts it
malignity I'm number one on the list the
most malignant offense is a felony that
I have to admit is unknown to me that of
vacating records number six is returning
from transportation also an offence
rarely seen in our modern society
numbers 10 to 12 are barratry
maintenance and champa tree especially
dear to me because they involve my
profession but rarely pursued these days
I think you'll agree and at number 15 is
perjury now if there's Madison told us
Blackstone was in the hand of every man
what does that tell us about why the
framers chose treason and bribery and
other high crimes and misdemeanors as
the grounds for impeachment it tells us
that they fully understood a comparative
gravity of offenses against public
justice and nonetheless chose only those
that truly posed that danger to the
state treason for obvious reasons and
bribery because to them the risk that
the executive would sell himself to a
foreign country for example was much
more than mere speculation and then
other other high crimes of similar
severity now as to the lessons to be
learned from the more modern day the
Sentencing Guidelines mr. manager
McCallum argued you to you a few weeks
ago that those to whom you have given
the responsibility to assess the
comparative severity of crimes have
concluded that perjury is at least as
serious a crime as bribery that decision
he told you is evidenced by the
Commission's decision to assign to
perjury an offense level of 12
approximately one year in prison and to
bribery and offense level slightly below
that but even to the extent that such an
argument were to be weighed in a
constitutional balance manager McCallum
was simply not being candid with you
before he failed to explain that under
these same guidelines a bribe of let's
say 75 thousand dollars taken by an
elected official or a judge for that
matter automatically carries an offense
level of twenty four twice that of
perjury and a prison sentence four to
five times longer the drafters of our
guidelines to the extent that manager
McCollum asks you to look at full well
understand the special gravity of bribes
taken by the country's leaders and are
prepared to distinguish that offense
from the offenses even at best that are
before you now and lastly the system of
Justice argument the notion that somehow
President Clinton has undermined our
civil rights laws well whatever I might
say could not match the eloquence of my
colleague in his Mills and therefore I
will not tempt fate by venturing further
into that territory I really don't want
to become further immersed in the
minutiae I here on this I do agree with
the managers we cannot lose sight of the
constitutional forest for some of the
analytical trees there is only one
question before you albeit a difficult
one one that is a question of fact and
law and constitutional theory would it
put at risk the liberties of the people
to retain the president in office
putting aside partisan animus if you can
honestly say that it would not that
those liberties are safe in his hands
then you must vote to acquit
now each of you has a sense of this in
your mind in your heart better than
anything I could convey or I suspect
anything better than my colleagues could
convey to you and I won't undertake to
instruct you further on this issue and
just as we ultimately leave that
question in your hands we leave to the
conscience of each member the question
of what standard of proof to apply
despite congressman Boyer's exhortation
to the contrary this body has never
decided for any of you what standard is
appropriate what standard inappropriate
each senator is left to his or her own
best judgment I suggested to you when I
last spoke to you but I believe you must
apply a standard sufficiently stringent
to enable you to make this most
important decision with certainty and in
a manner that will ensure that the
American people understand that it has
been made with that certainty this is
not an issue as to which we as a people
and we as a republic can be in doubt
let me move to the articles just as you
have listened patiently to our debate
about the meaning of high crimes and
misdemeanors you have as well heard
seemingly endless discourse about the
specific details of the various matters
that the managers allege constitute
grounds for removal I will strive there
not therefore not to be unduly
repetitive more than is at least
absolutely necessary my colleagues last
Saturday and in their earlier
presentations have done my work for me
but I want to focus for just a little
while on those aspects of the manager's
presentation that merit your special
attention or those that have been
particularly elucidated or for that
matter but clouded by the testimony you
heard and watched on Saturday as we
start this discussion let me offer you a
phrase that I hope you will remember as
I move through the articles with you
that phrase is moving targets and empty
pots moving targets ever shifting
theories each one advance to replace the
last as it has fallen fallen victim to
the facts empty pots attractive
containers but when you take the lid off
you find nothing to sustain you now I
use the term empty vessels in my opening
presentation but it's since struck me
that that was much too flattering and
might even suggest that they had the
capacity to float which they don't
particle one the first moving target as
we've said repeatedly we've been more
than a little puzzled as to the exact
nature of the charges advanced by the
managers under the rubric of article 1
and our puzzlement has only increased I
must tell you since this trial began
we've argued I think with indisputable
force that
both articles are so deficient that they
would not survive a motion to dismiss in
any court in the land and we're not
insensitive to the claim that we are
advancing some lawyer's argument we're
seeking some technical escape but I urge
you not to treat this issue so lightly
as you look to article 1 for example ask
yourselves whether you can at this late
moment in the trial identify for
yourselves with any remote sense of
certainty the statements that the
managers claim of perjurious I suspect
you will hear a lot about that in two
hours following my presentation but I'll
try to look ahead just a bit ask
yourselves whether you are comfortable
in this gravest of proceedings that when
you retire to your deliberations you
could ever know that the
constitutionally required two-thirds
vote is present on any one charge now
we've been making this argument excuse
me for some time and with some frequency
and so you would think that at least
once the trial began the managers would
have fixed on some definable set of
charges but no indeed it struck me even
earlier this afternoon that when manager
Sensenbrenner rose to speak to you he
was prepared to give you four examples
of perjury I've heard a lot of examples
we haven't heard much certainty now just
to give you an example of how rapidly
the target can move you'll recall that
in describing the incidence of perjury
allegedly committed by the president the
managers made much of the preliminary
statement he read to the grand jury
including the use of the words
occasionally and on certain occasions to
describe the frequency of certain
conduct and made the general allegation
that the statement was itself part of
the scheme to deceive the grand jury yet
strangely
when mr. manager broke and was asked
about these very charges as late as
January 20th he quite clearly
abandon them I direct your attention to
the exhibits before you and to the chart
appearing on television on January 20th
with Chris Matthews this is what
transpired mr. Matthews now defend these
elements one that the president lied
when he had said these relationships
with her on certain occasions is that
the language represented rogen that is
the and Matthews and why is that
perjurious perjurious representative
Rogan in fact I'm not I don't think it's
necessarily perjurious that is that's
one little piece of this answer he gave
at the grand jury Matthews well another
time he used a phrase with regard to
this ridiculous thing called phone sex
he referred to it as occasional on
occasion why do you add them in as part
of the perjury indictment representative
Brogan that's not added in as part of
the perjury indictment in article one I
simply raised that issue when I was
addressing the Senate Matthews you
better get to those senators because I
think they made the mistake I did of
thinking that was one of the elements in
the perjury charge and similarly over
here although I've reversed the order a
bit go through what you think are the
main elements representative Rogan one
of the things they were focusing on is a
point I think I made last week when I
was presenting the case for perjury
dealing with that preliminary statement
that the president read that just really
gave the grand jury a misperception of
what the president's relationship was
with Monica Lewinsky now I never said
that was the basis for the perjury
charge in fact that's not one even of
the four areas that's alleged but
they're trying to pick these little dots
out of the matrix and try to hang their
hat on that
well I have to tell you as did mr.
Matthews
I made the same mistake I heard manager
rodents a quote this prepared statement
he read to the grand jury on August 7th
Eve 1998 was the linchpin in his plan to
quote Wynne unquote I heard him say it
is obvious that the reference and the
president's prepared statement to the
grand jury that this relationship began
in 1996 was intentionally false I heard
him say the president's statement was
intentionally misleading when he
described being alone with Miss Lewinsky
only on certain occasions and I heard
him say the president's statement was
intentionally misleading when he
described his telephone conversations
with Monica Lewinsky as occasionally
that's what I heard one manager Rogan
spoke to you a few weeks ago now I know
it's unusual to be given a bill of
particulars on television and maybe
that's part of the modern litigation age
and so as to articles of one's charge
now that this is off the books that the
president perjured himself concerning
his relationship with Miss Lewinsky we
are once again left with the claim that
he lied about touchy about his denial
that he engaged in conduct that fell
within his subjective understanding of
the definition used in the Jones
deposition this in the course of
testimony members of the Senate in which
the president had already made the
single most devastating admission that
any of us can conceive that it defies
common sense and as any experienced
prosecutor and five experienced
prosecutor said this to the Judiciary
Committee will tell you it defines
real-world experience
to charge anyone President or not with
perjury on the ground that you
disbelieve his testimony about his own
subjective belief and a definition of a
used in a civil deposition nothing in
the evidentiary record has changed since
the OIC referred this matter to the
house six months ago and indeed it is
impossible to conceive what could change
in the evidentiary record and the
managers have offered this charge and
persist in it for reasons not entirely
clear to me but some blind faith that
they must go forward facts or no now
there are three other elements to
article one first that the allegation
the first the allegation that the
president lied when he claimed they did
not perjured himself in the Jones
deposition president of course made no
such representation in the grand jury
and the managers cannot no matter how
they try resurrect the charges of the
article then article 2 that was so
clearly rejected by the House of
Representatives yet if you listen to
their presentations over the past weeks
it becomes evident that whether
intentionally or unintentionally they
themselves have come to the point where
the president's testimony on January
17th in the Jones deposition and August
17th in the grand jury are treated as
though they were one in the same now
just week just a few minutes ago you
heard manager geekus talk to you about
perjury and probably 90% of what he
talked to you about was perjury in the
Jones case in the Jones case doesn't
exist anymore the House of
Representatives determined that that was
not an impeachable offense it appears to
make no difference though that the House
rejected this charge for the managers do
continue to dwell on it as though
somehow they could show the house map of
the house from which they came that they
made a mistake only last Saturday
manager Graham could be heard decrying
the present
claimed that he had never been alone
with monica lewinsky something that
comes not out of the grand jury but out
of the Jones deposition at the same time
he was taking him to task for his
disposition on the meaning of the word
is something that is in the grand jury
but is entirely irrelevant for these
perjury charges you could even see it in
their videotape presentation last
Saturday when snippets from January 17th
and August 17th were played without any
definition and without any sense that
there was any distinction between the
two events there's literally nothing in
the president's grand jury testimony
that purports to adopt whole city his
testimony in the Jones deposition if
anything it's evident that he's
explaining at length and clarifying and
adding to his deposition testimony
indeed even if article the original
article 2 had survived the president's
belief that he had worked quote worked
through the minefield of the Jones
deposition without violating the law
which is a quote from his grand jury
testimony could not allow the managers
somehow to establish that that statement
was independently perjurious and they
surely cannot do so now that the
original article two has disappeared as
to the second and third remaining
elements of article one that he
president lied about mr. Bennett's
statement to judge Wright at the time of
the Jones deposition and that he lied
about his own statements to his staff I
will deal with them in my discussion of
the obstruction charges in article two
suffice it to say that nothing in the
record as it came to you in January
could support conviction on article 1
and nothing added to the record since
then has changed that result
let me move to article two
manager Hutchinson told you in his
original presentation that article two
rested on in his words seven pillars of
obstruction I had suggested in my
opening statement of a few weeks ago
that would be more accurate to call them
seven shifting sand castles of
speculation but manager Hutchinson has
not proved willing to accept my
description and so I will accept kids
let's remove one pillar right at the
start
article two charges that the president
engaged in a scheme to obstruct the
Jones case the Jones case and alleges as
one element of this scheme that in the
days following January 21st the
president lied to his staff about his
relationship with Miss Lewinsky conduct
that could not possibly have had
anything to do with the Jones litigation
I will get to the merits of that charge
standing alone in a little while but I
bring up the more forgive me technical
argument here to highlight once more the
extent to which the house simply ignored
the most basic legal principles and
bringing these charges to you I have yet
to hear from the managers a single
plausible explanation for the inclusion
of this charge as part of a scheme to
obstruct the Jones litigation and I can
think of mine I'm sure that in a hundred
and twenty minutes remaining to them
some portion of that time will be
explained will be spent explaining just
this point and so one pillar gone a
slight list observed next
Ms Lewinsky's affidavit and the first of
the empty pots the managers charge that
the president corruptly encouraged a
witness to execute a sworn affidavit
that he knew to be perjury Asst false
and misleading and similarly encouraged
miss Lewinsky to lie if she were ever
called as a witness in my opening
statement and mr. Kendall's more
detailed discussion we made two points
first that miss Lewinsky had repeatedly
denied that she had ever been asked or
encouraged to lie and second that there
was simply no direct or circumstantial
evidence that the President had ever
done such a thing now it's not in
dispute that the president called miss
Lewinsky on the early morning of
December 17th to tell her about the
death of Betty Curry's brother and in
the same call that he told her that she
was now listed on the Jones witness list
the managers have from the beginning
relied on one fact and on one baseless
hypothesis stemming from this call which
in the managers minds was the beginning
and the middle and the end of the scheme
to encourage the filing of a false
affidavit there was literally no other
event or statement on which they can
rely on the one fact to which the
managers point is ms Lewinsky's
testimony that the president said that
if she were actually subpoenaed she
possibly could file an affidavit to
avoid having to testify and at some
point in the call mentioned one of the
so-called
cover stories that they had used when
she was still working at the White House
that is bringing papers to him and it is
on this shaky foundation a very slim
pillar indeed that the managers build
there
in the face of the seemingly
insurmountable hurdle of MS Lewinsky's
repeated denials that anyone ever asked
or encouraged her to lie the managers
have persisted in arguing and continue
to do so that the President did somehow
encourage her to lie even if she didn't
know it now you've heard that theme
sounded really for the first time on
Saturday and then a little bit today
even if she didn't know it because both
really understood that any affidavit
miss Lewinsky would follow would have to
be false if it were to result in her
avoiding her deposition but neither the
fact on which they were lying
nor their hypothesis was of much help to
the managers before Ms Lewinsky's
deposition and neither surely has any
force after deposition after you saw
Miss Lewinsky testimony there can be
nothing left of what was at best only
conjecture even before her deposition
miss Lewinsky had testified as had the
president in the grand jury that given
the claims being made in the John's case
a truthful albeit limited affidavit
might might establish that Miss Lewinsky
had nothing relevant to offer in the way
of testimony in the John's pills faced
with this record the managers asked you
to authorize his lewinsky's deposition
representing that she would and I quote
and this is from the managers proper
rebuttal the following inferences drawn
by white House Counsel on key issues
among others that President Clinton did
not encourage miss Lewinsky to file a
false affidavit and that President
Clinton did not have an understanding
with Miss Lewinsky that the two would
lie under oath unhappily for the
managers and perhaps their unhappiness
was best reflected in the tone of
manager Bryant's discussion
subject ms Lewinsky's testimony as you
saw yourself on saturday did just the
opposite in an extended colloquy with
mr. manager brian on the subject of the
affidavit miss Lewinsky made clear
beyond any doubt
first that the president had never
discussed a contents of the affidavit
with him second that there was no
connection between the suggestion that
she might file an affidavit and the
reference to any cover store
third that she believed it possible to
file a truthful affidavit
now you saw much of this portion of Miss
Lewinsky deposition on Saturday and I'm
not going to impose too much on your
patience but I do want to play just a
very few segments of that videotape
first two segments dealing with a
content of the affidavit are you
that he making strike it we did he make
any representation to you about what you
could say in that affidavit or no what
did you understand you would be saying
in that affidavit to avoid testifying I
believe I've testified to this and the
grand jury and the best of my
recollection it was to my mind it came
it was a range of things I mean he could
either be something innocuous or could
go as far as having to deny the
relationship not being a lawyer nor
having gone to law school was I thought
it could be anything
that he at that point suggests one
version of the other version no I didn't
even mention that so that there wasn't a
further discussion there was no
discussion of what would be in an
affidavit in his answer to this
proceeding in the Senate he has
indicated that he thought he had might
have had a way that he could have you
get you to Folly basically a true
affidavit but yet still skirt these
issues enough that you wouldn't be
called as a witness did he offer you any
of these suggestions at this time he
didn't discuss the content of my
affidavit with me at all ever next a
couple of brief segments on the issue of
the cover stories they take just a
moment here you are
well based on prior relations with the
president the concocted stories and
those things like that did this come to
mind was there some discussion about
that or did it come to your mind about
connection with the affidavit did you
discuss anything else that night and in
terms of I would draw your attention to
the cover stories I've alluded to that
earlier but did you did you talk about
cover story that night yes sir
and what was saying I believe that the
president said something you can always
say you were coming to see Betty or
bringing me papers
I think you've testified that you're
sure he said that that it that night you
are sure he said it that night yes now
what was that in connection with the
affidavit I don't believe so no now you
have testified in the in the grand jury
I think your closing comments was that
no one ever asked you to lie but yet in
that very conversation of December the
17th 1997 when the president told you
that you were on the witness list he
also suggested that you could sign an
affidavit and use misleading cover
stories in that correct
but I guess in my mind I separate
necessarily signing affidavit and using
misleading cover story so well those two
those three events occurred but they
don't they weren't linked for me and
third a brief segment on the supposed
falsity of any affidavit that might be
filed
the night of the phone call he suggested
you could file an affidavit did you
appreciate the implications of filing a
false affidavit with the with the court
I don't think I necessarily thought at
that point it would have to be false so
no probably not
I don't I don't remember having any
thoughts like that so I imagine I would
remember something like that and I don't
but and last if we might a brief segment
on the question of whose interests were
being served
but you didn't filed an affidavit for
your best interest issue
actually I did to avoid testifying yes
brief but pointed I think and I'm sure
you remember them from Saturday and I'm
sure you'll take those excerpts with you
as you move into your deliberations now
there was another issue that surfaced
early on although perhaps it has
dissipated and that is whether the
president ever saw a draft of Miss
Lewinsky affidavit something that the
managers alleged early on but indeed as
we now know from that testimony not only
did nobody ever see a draft of the
affidavit the president and Miss
Lewinsky never even discussed the
content of her affidavit not ever as she
put it either on December 17th or on
January 5th on any other date according
to miss Lewinsky the president told her
he didn't need to see a draft because
he'd seen other affidavits our Leon
manager McCullum speculated for you
speculated for you but when the
president told Ms Lewinsky that he
didn't need to see her affidavit because
he'd seen other affidavits he really
must have meant that he'd seen previous
drafts of hers and this is what he said
I doubt seriously the president was
talking about 15 other affidavits of
somebody else and didn't like looking at
affidavits anymore I suspect and I would
suggest to you that he was talking about
15 other drafts of this proposed
affidavit since it had been around the
horn a lot of rounds
that's what manager McCallum told you
well now we know that those drafts
simply didn't exist they never existed
how do we know well somewhat belatedly
the managers got around to telling us
that in describing the testimony that
they would expect to receive from Miss
Lewinsky when they moved here for the
like to take her deposition they wrote
in their motion that same day January
5th she called President Clinton to ask
if the president would like to review
her affidavit before it was signed he
declined saying he had already seen
about 15 others she understood that to
mean that he had seen 15 other
affidavits rather than 15 prior drafts
of her affidavit parentheses which did
not exist close parentheses in some one
the only reference to an affidavit in
the December 17th call was the
suggestion of the president that filing
one might possibly enable miss Lewinsky
to avoid being deposed itself an
entirely legitimate and proper
suggestion to the president miss
Lewinsky never discussed the content of
her affidavit on or after December 17 3
the president never saw or read any
draft of the affidavit before it was
sawn for the president believed that she
could file a true affidavit 5 miss
Lewinsky believed that she could file a
true affidavit 6 there is not one single
document or piece of testimony that
suggests that the president encouraged
her to file a false alphadon
well if there is no proof that the
president encouraged miss Lewinsky to
file a false affidavit surely there must
be some proof for the other charge that
he encouraged her to give perjurious
testimony if she were ever called to
testify
well there isn't let's begin by noting
something that should help you assess
the president's actions during this
period both the charge that he
encouraged the filing of a false
affidavit and the charge that he
encouraged miss Lewinsky to testify
falsely
a conversation that the manners allege
gave rise to both offenses is that call
of the early morning of December 17th
and the managers suggest that the
president in essence used the subterfuge
of a call to inform miss Lewinsky about
the death of Miss Curry's brother to
discuss her status as a witness in the
Jones case subterfuge come on a tragedy
had befallen a woman who was miss
lewinsky friend and the president's
secretary but let's put this in the
manager's own context on December 6th
the president learned that Miss Lewinsky
was on the Jones witness list according
to the matters that was a source of
grave concern and spurred intensified
efforts to find her a job efforts that
we're still further intensified when on
December 11th judge Wright issued her
order allowing lawyers to inquire into
president's relationships with other
women yet I have not heard any
explanation as to why the president now
theoretically so distraught that he was
urging mr. Jordan to keep miss Lewinsky
happy by finding her a job as manager
Hutchinson would have it waited until
December 17th 11 days after he learned
Miss Lewinsky was on the witness list
and six days after supposedly critical
events of December 11th to call and
launch his aim to suborn perjury now as
to the charge of supper nation the
president managers do concede as they
must that the president in his
skee did not even discuss her deposition
on the 17th logically I suppose and she
wasn't actually subpoenaed until two
days later and one might think that this
would dispose of the matter since they
do not identify a single other moment in
time when there was any discussion of
his lewinsky's potential testimony but
once again having lifted the lid and
seen that their pot was empty they would
ask you to find that the same signal
that we now know did not encourage the
filing of an affidavit was a signal to
Miss Lewinsky to lie if she was over
called to testify but of course we've
long known that there was no such signal
and the grand jury as was so often the
case one of the jurors took it upon him
or herself to ask that which the
independent counsel chose not to and you
have this before you and you've seen it
before
a juror it is possible that you also
have these discussions about denying the
relationship after you learned that you
were a witness in the Paula Jones case
there's Lewinsky I don't believe so no a
juror can you exclude that possibility
as Lewinsky I pretty much can I really
don't remember it I mean it would be
very surprising for me to be confronted
with something that would show me
different but I it was 2:30 and they I
mean the conversation I'm thinking of
mainly would have to have been December
17th which was a joy the telephone call
miss Lewinsky right and it was you know
2:00 2:30 in the morning I remember the
gist of it and I I really don't think so
a juror thank you
but all of this is not enough to
dissuade the managers now that they know
that the only two participants in the
relevant conversation deny that there
was any discussion of either the
affidavit or the testimony they have
created still another theory as manager
Brian told you last week and in essence
it was repeated today quote I don't care
what was in mine is lewinsky's mind well
that is quite extraordinary the only
witness the supposed victim of the
obstruction the person whose testimony
is being influenced says that it didn't
happen and the managers nonetheless
wants you to conclude I assume that some
subliminal message was being conveyed
that resulted in the filing of a false
affidavit without the affiant knowing
that she was being controlled by some
unseen and unheard force I won't comment
further to more Pilar's lie in the dust
next the gifts
on this charge the record is largely but
in critical respects not entirely as the
record has been from the beginning here
is what it shows in the morning of
December 28th the president gave miss
Lewinsky Christmas presents in token of
her impending departure from New York
mrs. Lewinsky testified that she raised
the subject of her subpoena and said
something about getting the gifts out of
her apartment - which is she herself has
now told you the president either made
no response or said something like let
me think about how Betty curry has
testified consistently that Miss
Lewinsky called her to ask her to pick
up a box and hold them for her as the
windiest testified equally consistent
testified again in her deposition it was
her recollection that Mr curry called
her and said that she understood she
quote had something for her or perhaps
even the president said you have
something for me the president denies
that he ever spoke to Betty curry about
picking up gifts from Monica Lewinsky
Betty curry denies that the president
ever asked her to pick up gifts from
Monica Lewinsky now Miss Lewinsky has
stated on three occasions before her
most recent deposition the miss curry
picked up the gifts at two o'clock in
the afternoon and on the 28th having
been shown the infamous 332 cell phone
call which had previously been trumpeted
by the managers as absolutely prove that
it was miss curry who called his
Lewinsky to initiate the process as
Lewinsky testified on Monday that miss
Perry came to pick up the gifts sometime
during the afternoon and that there had
been other calls earlier in the day
but we learned at least a couple of
interesting new things from Miss
Lewinsky on this subject first when she
received her subpoena on December 19th
nine day he's nine days before she spoke
to the president about them miss
Lewinsky was frightened at the prospect
that the Jones lawyers would search her
apartment and she began to think about
concealing the gifts that she cared most
about or that would suggest some special
relationship with the president and as
she told you she herself decided then
that she would turn over only what she
described as the most innocuous gifts
and it was those gifts that she took
with her to see her lawyer mr. Carter on
December 22nd
thus when she arrived to pick up her
Christmas gifts from the president on
December 28th she had already decided
that she would not turn over all the
gifts called for by the subpoena and had
already segregated out the ones she
intended to with whole but she didn't
tell the president about that instead as
she testified she broached the question
of what to do with the gifts and the
possibility of the giving them to Betty
curry again without describing what had
already occurred to which the president
either made no reply or said something
like I'll think about it
this testimony sheds light on one of the
issues that is troubled everyone was
tried to make sense out of what happened
on that day
why would the president if he were
really worried about his Lewinsky's
turning over gifts pursuant to the
subpoena give her more gifts from our
perspective the answers already has
always been an easy one it wouldn't have
been concerned he's testified that he's
not concerned about gifts that he gives
them all the time to all sorts of people
and he wasn't worried about it now we
know that from Miss Lewinsky perspective
as she explained in her deposition it
also made no difference that the
president was giving her additional
gifts because she had already decided
having had the subpoena in hand for
days that she would not turn them over
now a second ray of light also shines on
two aspects of the manager's case from
is Louis's deposition you examine may
remember that as part of article 1 in
their trial brief the managers allege
that the president lied to the grand
jury this is one of the never ending
list of possible perjuries that he were
called saying to Miss Lewinsky on
December 28th that she would have to
quote turn over whatever she had unquote
when she raised the gift issue with her
while the manager sought to obtain from
his Lewinsky testimony that would
support that charge of perjury as well
as the concealment charge under Article
two but she turned their world upside
down on both the perjury charge and the
obstruction charge when asked whether
the President had ever said to her you
will have to give them whatever you have
or something like that
his Lewinsky testified that FBI agent
Phelan of the OIC had interviewed her
after the president's grand jury
testimony after they already knew what
the President had said under oath and
asked her whether she recalled the
president's saying anything like that to
her and I'm sure somewhat to the
surprise of manager Braun it she
testified that she told agent Fallon
that sounds familiar
now aside from the not so minor point
that mr. Winston's testimony
corroborates the president's
recollection of his response and
undermines the charge for both article 1
in article 2 a couple of other things
are worth noting as my colleague Miss
Seligmann pointed out to you Saturday
this was the first time after all miss
Lewinsky recorded versions of the events
of December 28th that we had ever heard
that the president's version sounded
familiar to
and second there is not a single piece
of paper at least that we're aware of in
the entire universe turned over by the
independent counsel to the house and
thence to us that reflects the FBI's
interview of Miss Lewinsky if she hadn't
been honest enough to tell manager
Bryant about it we and you would never
have known senators what else is there
in the vaults of the Independent Counsel
or in the memory of his agents that we
don't know about another pillar down
the job search and may have become
tiresome to hear it but any discussion
of the job search must begin with Miss
Lewinsky testimony oft-repeated that no
one promised her a job to influence her
testimony remember my two themes moving
targets empty pots they come together
here but the managers have presented to
you as a series of different speculative
theories as each one is shown to be what
it is they move on to the next in the
hope they will find one someday that
actually has a connection to reality but
they cannot find that elusive theory for
the stubborn facts will not budge nor
will the stubborn denials by every
participant in their mythical clock now
we know that miss Lewinsky job search
began in the summer of 97 well in
advance of her being involved in the
Jones case in October she interviewed
with UN Ambassador Richardson was
offered a job she had her first meeting
with mr. Jordan early in November well
before she appeared in the Jones case
the next contact was actually before
Thanksgiving when she made an effort to
set up another meeting mr. Jordan was
told to call back after the holiday she
did on December 8th and set up a meeting
on December 11th again before either she
or mr. Jordan knew that she was involved
in the Jones case now on that date of
December 11th which we've heard so much
about
mr. Jordan did open doors from his
Lewinsky in New York but there was no
inappropriate pressure at American
Express in Young & Rubicam
she failed on her own and at Revlon she
succeeded on him as mr. Jordan told the
grand jury when asked whether there was
any connection between his assistance to
her and the Jones case his answer was
unequivocally indubitably no in search
of some efforts that mr. Jordan had some
evidence that mr. Jordans efforts were
indeed triggered by
miss Lewinsky status is witness and
therefore possibly inappropriate the
managers focus on his January 8th call
mr. Perlman the CEO of McAndrews and
Forbes admittedly a date by which his
whiskey status was known to her mr.
Jordan and to the president as the
Winsky had reported that our original
interview had not gone well although we
know it actually had and that her resume
had already been sent over from the
kandar's and Forbes to Brad LAN where
she was ultimately offered a job as
Jordan was candid in stating that he
went to the top because he wanted to get
action if action could be had but the
record is clear that the woman involved
at Revlon who interviewed is Lewinsky
had already made a decision to hire no
one put any pressure on her there was no
special urgency there was no fix in fact
if you want to know what happens when
mr. Jordan calls the CEO of the company
to get action look at his call to the
CEO of Young & Rubicam no job no job
they made an independent decision
whether or not to hire is the windspeed
now other than the managers there are
only two people as far as I can tell
whoever tried to create a link between
the job search and the affidavit when
the trip Kenneth Starr no one mr. Winsky
mr. Jordan off the president no one ever
said anything that so much as suggests
the existence of such a linkage and the
managers can find no proof which is not
to say they didn't try manager
Hutchinson you'll recall originally
asked you to look at the events of
January 5th when he said that Miss
Lewinsky had met with her attorney mr.
Carter and then according to the
managers account
mr. Carter began drafting the affidavit
and Miss Lewinsky was so concerned that
she called the president and he returned
her call well the problem with this
version as my colleague
mr. Kendall showed you was the affidavit
wasn't drafted till January 6 mr. Carter
is so testified now the managers would
also have you believe that mr. Jordan
was involved in drafting the affidavit
and that he was involved in the deletion
of language from the draft that
suggested that she'd been alone with the
president miss Lewinsky as in mr.
Jordans testimony is essentially the
same they talked
mr. Jordan listen you recall him saying
yes she was talking and I was doodling
he called mr. Carter he transmitted to
mr. Carter some of her concerns but he
made it very clear to miss Lewinsky he
wasn't a lawyer and in words that will
resonate forever at least among the
legal community
mr. Jordan said I don't do affidavits
and of course mr. Carter himself
testified it was his idea to delete the
language about being alone now the very
best that the managers can do on this
issue is to establish that Miss Lewinsky
talked to mr. Jordan in the same
conversation about the job search and
about her affidavit but as mr. jordan
told you miss Lewinsky was always
talking about the job search and he made
it very clear to you that there was no
linkage between the two if we can play
just a very brief segment of mr. Jordans
deposition
in your conversation with Miss Lewinsky
prior to the affidavit being signed did
you in fact talk to her about both the
job and her concerns about parts of the
affidavit
I have never in any conversation with
Miss Lewinsky talk to her about the job
on one hand our job being interrelated
with the conversation about the
affidavit the affidavit was over here
the job was over here but the and of
course we've already dispensed with the
notion to the extent that the man who's
continued to assert it that the
president ever discussed the contents of
the affidavit but Miss Lewinsky or even
oversaw a draft now recognizing that
they would never be able to show that
the inception of the job search was
linked in any way to the affidavit
managers developed a theory which
they've advanced to you that the
president committed obstruction of
justice when the job search assistance
became in their words quote totally in
connect interconnected intertwined
interrelated unquote with the filing of
Miss Lewinsky affidavit the problem the
managers have had however is that
they've not been able to figure out when
this occurred why it occurred or how it
occurred think back on how many versions
of their theory you have heard just in
the last few weeks first it all started
on December 11th when Judge Wright
issued her order permitting the Jones
lawyers to take depositions to prove
that the president had relations with
other women
that was what galvanized the president
and mr. Jordan to make real efforts to
find mr. Winsky a job whoops didn't
quite fit the facts mr. Jordan met with
Liu Miss Lewinsky and made calls to
prospective employers before the order
was issued all right let's try this
well it wasn't really the 11 TC it was
the fifth when the witness with Lisp
came out but they'd already told you in
their trial brief quite explicitly and
in the majority report of the committee
to the Congress that there was no
urgency those there was there was no
urgency after December 5th I'm a city
boy but that dog went back to sleep
third as manager hutchinson told you on
Saturday what really happened was that
by December 17th the president had quote
got the job search moving and fought
quote maybe she's now more receptive
unquote and that's why he called miss
Lewinsky on the 17th and told her she
was on the witness list nice try
no facts
now I don't know whether this chart
which manager Hutchinson used was
intended to speak for itself
or to be elucidated by his own comments
well let's look at it
December 5th witness list Lewinsky
exclamation point true but this list
comes out Monica Lewinsky's name is
gonna say December 6th president meets
with attorneys on witness list true 7th
President and Jordan meet well that's
also true but we know I didn't talk
about Monica Lewinsky not quite sure why
it's there December 8th Lewinsky sets up
a meeting with Jordan for the 11th true
at that point she doesn't know she's on
the list
mr. Jordan doesn't know he's a that
she's on the list the 11th so the
windspeed job meeting with Jordan yes
true and as we know well before Judge
Wright's order came out they still don't
know the two of them that there is that
her name is on the witness list
December 17th the call true they're on
the list
December 19th the subpoena is served
true December 28th president and
Lewinsky need and gifts are concealed
yeah true but I'm not sure what that
means in this context and last
interestingly breakfast at the park hire
more evidence at risk now it is clear
that if you spring all these events
together and you have a theory that will
link them all together you've made some
progress there's only one problem
other than what we know to be true on
this list there is nothing other than
surmise that links them together in any
fashion that one could consider improper
they're certainly illegal but that is in
essence where the managers have brought
us in their theorizing
where their fourth theory is that the
pressure did not really begin to build
until miss Lewinsky was actually
subpoenaed and began to prepare an
affidavit and on this theory a call to
mr. Perlman was the final step going
right to the top of McAndrews and forbes
to make absolutely sure that miss
Lewinsky
stayed on the team but here there are
other facts to deal with for example
look what happened or more importantly
didn't happen on December 19 on that day
Monica Lewinsky came weeping to mr.
Jordans office carrying with her the
dreaded subpoena mr. Jordan called the
President and visited with that visited
with him that evening and you recall
that he talked in very candid terms to
Miss Lewinsky and to mr. Jordan about
their relationship and she's mean to the
president about their relationship
wouldn't one think that if the president
was in fact engaged in some scheme to
use a job in New York to influence Miss
Lewinsky his testimony that this would
be the critical moment that some
immediate steps would be taken to be
absolutely sure that there was a job for
look what do we find mr. Jordan takes no
further action on the job front until
January 8th now there was never so much
as a passing reference concerning any
connection between the job search in the
affidavit among any of the three
participants any of the three
participants
there's not one conversation that any
one could conclude was designed to
implement this
that the managers would have you fine
and so now we have an entirely new
theory a one-man conspiracy a beast
unknown I think to anglo-american
jurisprudence now the fact that Miss
Lewinsky didn't this is on the managers
there the fact that Miss Lewinsky didn't
know she was on the witness list until
December 17th and mr. Jordan didn't know
about it until she was subpoenaed on the
19th and mr. Pearlman never knew it all
are proof positive that the President
himself was the mastermind pulling on
unseen strings and influencing the
participants in this drama without their
even knowing that they were being
influenced under this theory the latest
in the long line his lewinsky's denial
that she ever discussed the contents of
Rafa day with the president her denial
that there was any connection between
the job and her testimony mr. Jordans
denial that there was any connection
between his efforts to find a job and
the affidavit and the fact that mr.
Jordan never discussed any such
connection with the president are simply
evidence of the fact that there must
have been such a connection that
unbeknownst to Miss Lewinsky she was
being corruptly encouraged to file a
false affidavit with all due respect
somebody's been watching too many reruns
of the x-files confronted with this
problem the managers now offer you one
last Theory with ever-increasing
directness they now accuse mr. Jordan
himself of obstructing justice
by urging miss Lewinsky to destroy her
notes seemingly they asked you to find
even in the face of mr. Jordans forceful
denials that one who would forget a
breakfast at the Park Hyatt until
reminded of it by being shown the
receipt and who would then admit that
his recollection was refreshed and who
would admit that he remembered a
discussion of the notes must have
obstructed justice himself and of course
must have been engaged
along with an effort to influence miss
lewinsky testimony on behalf of the
president nonsense nonsense
and so this pillar returns to the dust
from which it came next the charge that
the events surrounding mr. Bennett's
statement to judge right during the
Jones deposition formed the basis for to
chart they formed the basis for two
charges first that the president
obstructed justice in the Jones case and
second that he committed perjury by
telling the grand jury that he really
wasn't paying attention at the critical
moment both charges depend on the
managers ability to prove that indeed
the president hadn't had been paying
attention to do that they had always
relied on the videotape of the
deposition in which it can be seen that
the president was looking in the
direction of his lawyer while mr.
Bennett was talking but two weeks ago
two weeks ago they came to you and they
produced with a modest flourish a new
bit of evidence an affidavit from mr.
Barry Ward clerk to judge Wright
trumpeted in their words as quote
lending even greater credence to their
claim now in their memorandum in support
of their request to expand the record by
including mr. Ward's out the David the
managers told you the following and this
is the manager's own language from his
seat at the conference table next to the
judge he saw President Clinton listening
attentively to mr. Bennett's remarks
while the exchange between mr. Bennett
and the judge occurred further the
managers say mr. Ward's declaration
would lend even greater credence to the
argument that President Lincoln lied on
that President Clinton lied on this
point during his grand jury testimony
and obstructed justice by allowing his
attorney to utilize a false affidavit in
order to cut off a legitimate line of
questioning mr. Ward's declaration
proves that mr. Ward saw President
Clinton listening attentively
while the exchange between mr. Bennett
and the presiding judge occurred but
this is what mr. Ward's affidavit
actually says the affidavit that was
attached to the very motion a language
from which I just read to you and I
direct your attention only to the last
sentence because this is the only one of
any moment from my position at the
conference table
I observed President Clinton looking
directly at mr. Bennett
while this statement was being made
search if you will for any evidence
relating to whether the president was
looking attentively and not there is not
one iota of evidence added to the
videotape you were misled indeed mr.
Ward said to the legal Times on February
1st 1999 I have no idea if he was paying
attention it could have been thinking
about policy initiatives for all I know
you were misled the record before the
affidavit is the record after the
affidavit the managers asked that you
removed the President of the United
States on the basis of a videotape
showing that he was looking in the
direction of his lawyer well it wasn't
much of a poem to start with
there's no dispute and we move now to
the conversation of January 18th with
between the president and mrs. curry
there's no dispute that President
Clinton called miss curry into the White
House on Sunday January 18th the day
after his deposition and asked her
certain questions and made certain
statements about his relationship with
mr. MS Lewinsky the only dispute is
whether in doing so the president
intended to tamper with a witness
managers contend that he was corrupt Lee
attempting to influence ms curries
testimony the president denies it now
since we know that Ms curry was not on
the Jones witness list at the time of
the president's deposition or at the
time of either of his conversations with
Miss curry and we know that discovery
was about to end the managers have
argued that the president's own
references to her in the Jones
deposition constituted an invitation to
the Jones lawyers to subpoena and they
argue that proof of that invitation can
be found in a witness list
signed by the Jones lawyers On January
22nd which listed miss curry and 17
other potential witnesses and when I
spoke to you on January 19th I told you
and MS curry had never been placed on a
witness list I was wrong and manager
Hutchinson has quite properly taken me
to task for it but I fear that he's
become so caught up in this new
information that he has lost sight of
its true significance or rather lack
thereof in order to convince you that
Betty curry was going to be called by
the Jones lawyers when the president
spoke to her On January 18 the managers
somewhat like Diogenes lit their Lantern
and sought out the most reliable witness
they could find a witness whose
credibility was beyond question who had
no ulterior motive no bias Paula Jones's
lawyer and they brought him to you in a
form that they hoped would allow his
motive and bias to go untested remember
how the managers have told you that it's
important
look and witness in the eye test his
demeanor I doubt that you need to do
that to understand what might color mr.
Holmes his view of the world so let's
look at what he had to say you having
the exhibits before you an unredacted
witness list attached to mr. Holmes
affidavit I've put up on the easels the
redacted list that was originally used
by the managers a few weeks ago because
I really see no purpose and unduly
exposing the names of the people who
were on that witness list but let me
direct you to these words just as the
side light under seal he'll remember
that the president has been character
criticized for violating the gag order
when he spoke to his own secretary of
that his deposition what then do we say
when the managers produce a document
from a lawyer for one of the parties
that is still under seal not yet
released by the court and reveals the
name of ended up in dividuals there were
no part of these proceedings
surely the managers could have made
their point just as well without such a
revelation
now mr. homn states that the Jones
lawyers had two reasons for putting mr.
E's name on the witness list
one because of President Clinton's
deposition testimony and two because
they had quote received what they
considered to be reliable information
that miss curry was instrumental in
facilitating Monica Lewinsky's meetings
with mr. Clinton and that miss curry was
central to the cover story mr. Clinton
and Miss Lewinsky had developed to use
in the event their affair was discovered
he doesn't tell us where he got this
reliable information but of course we
know it's miss trip but let's figure out
whether in fact Betty curry really made
it on the list because of the
president's testimony
if you look at the number of times that
she's mentioned in the deposition has
become conventional wisdom that the
president inserted her name
Andy was testimony so frequently and so
gratuitously that he did in fact invite
the Jones lawyers to call her and thus
must have known that she was going to be
a witness when he spoke to Ranjana rave
teams but if you look at the deposition
you'll find that the first time her name
is mentioned president is simply
responding to a question about his early
meetings with Miss Lewinsky and states
that betty was president the lawyers for
the plaintiff then asked 13 questions
give or take a few about miss curry and
we know there's no secret here they got
their information from Linda Tripp and
Linda Tripp Shirley told them about MS
Lewinsky's relationship with Miss Perry
it was only in response to a couple of
their questions about where the letters
had ever been delivered in history and
whether she stated some strongly a late
hour
that the president said you'll have to
ask her he didn't invite he didn't
suggest to them that they call him his
curry
they knew whatever they needed to know
about Miss curry to put her on their
witness list
now it's a judge further whether miss
curry made it onto the list at the
president's invitation or because they
already knew about witnesses from this
trip let me direct your attention if you
look at the exhibit in front of you
rather than the redacted version here
the person listed on a witness list at
number 165 her name does not come up at
all in the deposition but we know that
she was in fact the subject of
conversation surreptitiously recorded
between this trip and is the windspeed
and note to the name of Vernon Jordan
which is on this list they're the ones
the Jones lawyers the ones who first
bring him up and we know of course but
they knew from his trip that he was
already involved in this scenario thus
neither the January 22nd witness list
nor mr. Holmes affidavit supports the
managers theory President did not know
his curly would be a witness when he
spoke to her after her deposition he
could not therefore have tampered with
the witness well beyond well beyond
their statement about how they got this
information mr. Holmes volunteers that
they didn't get it from the Washington
Post well perhaps not but it's clear
that in the days after the post story
broke we know that some of the names on
the list came from the press reports we
know the drill Jones lawyers began
tracking the newly public activities of
the Independent Counsel which was
issuing its own subpoenas in the hours
and days following the story's release
and for some insight into what at least
the independent counsel thought was
going on look at the pleading they filed
with judge Wright on Wednesday January
28th to prevent the Jones lawyers from
continuing to use their investigation as
an aid that is the ICS investigation as
an aid to civil discovery the pleadings
said
as recently as this afternoon
plaintiff's counsel calls process to be
served on Betty curry who appeared
before the grand jury in Washington
yesterday
such deliberate and calculated shadowing
of the grand jury's investigation will
necessarily pierce the veil of grand
jury secrecy
now the managers have criticized us for
ignoring a second conversation between
the president and miss Perry suggesting
I suppose that it takes on an even more
sinister cast in the first but there's
simply nothing of any substance to take
from this second conversation but adds
to the events of January 18th it's clear
that the conversation occurred on
Tuesday January 20th
before the Starr investigation became
public the managers disingenuously have
suggested in their exhibits the one they
distributed on Saturday that this
conversation occurred after the post
story appeared and if you look to have
the exhibit that was used on Saturday
you'll see January 20th post story is
known of course that late at night
January 21st posted on the Internet
president calls Betty for 20 minutes and
then sort of sneaking it in down here
January 20th or 21st president coaches
hurry for the second time but the record
shows this miss curry has said that the
conversation occurred quote whenever the
president was next in the White House as
after the Sunday conversation and that
was Tuesday the 20th the day after the
Martin Luther King holiday thus the
second conversation is of no liquid or
legal significance than the first since
the president knew no more about his
curry status as a witness on Tuesday
than he did on Sunday and some of the
managers have tried to convince you that
the president moved or must have known
that betty curry would be a witness in
the Jones case if anything we now know
that the reason she was put on the
January 22nd list along with many others
had more to do with Linda trip than
anything else but putting this aside for
the moment that is putting aside the
question whether the president could
have had any reason to believe that miss
curry would be a witness look at whether
miss curry herself believed that she was
being corruptly influenced on January 18
in response to continuing efforts by the
prosecutors to get her to admit that she
felt some untoward pressure from the
president she testified and you've seen
this before as well did you feel
pressured when he told you those
statements
none whatsoever and what did you think
of what was going through your mind
about what he was doing at the time I
felt that he was I want to use the word
shocked or surprised that this was an
issue and he was just talking question
that was your impression that he wanted
you to say because he would end each of
the statements was right with a question
answer I do not remember that he wanted
me to say right he would say right and I
could have said wrong and at the end did
you feel any pressure to agree with your
boss no and so on a human level a human
level we have the president who has just
seen his worst nightmare come true and
who knows that he's about to face a
press tidal wave that will wash over him
and his family and a country we have his
secretary who knows of indeed has been a
part of his relationship with Monica
Lewinsky but knows nothing about the
long since ended improper aspects of
that relationship we have a conversation
that was the product of the emotions
that were churning through the
president's very soul on that day but we
do not have is an attempt corruptly to
influence the testimony of the witness
only one color left
managers asked the Senate to find that
the president's conversations with mr.
Blumenthal and other aides was an effort
to influence their testimony before the
grand jury
their theory much as was true of some of
their other theories founders on shoals
that they don't account for as they
would have it in the days immediately
following the Lewinsky story the
president spoke with a few members of
his senior staff as they would allege
knowing that they would probably be
grand jury witnesses and mislead them
about his relationship with Miss
Lewinsky
so that they would convey that
misinformation to the grand jury when
they were called now just so that you
can see for yourself what the president
testified to in the grand jury on this
subject I want to play about three or
four minutes of that testimony for you I
need you denying sexual relations or a
relationship with Monica Lewinsky or if
they've told us that you denied that do
you have any reason to doubt in the days
after the story broke do you have any
reason to doubt no the let me say this
it's no secret to anybody that I hope
that this relationship would never
become public it's a matter of fact that
it had been many many months since there
had been anything improper about it in
terms of improper contact
I realize I'm they finish so what I did
not want to mislead my friends but I
wanted to find a language where I could
say that I also frankly did not want to
turn any of them into witnesses because
I ensure enough they all became
witnesses well you knew them so and so I
said to them things that were true about
this relationship that I used in the in
the language I used I said there's
nothing going on between us that was
true I said I have not had sex with her
as I define it that was true and that I
hope that I would never have to be here
on this day giving this testimony of
course but I also didn't want to do
anything to complicate this matter
further
so I said things that were true they may
have been misleading and if they were I
have to take responsibility for it and
I'm sorry they may have been misleading
sir and you knew though after January
21st when the Post article broke and
said that Judge Starr was looking into
this he knew that they might be waiting
he knew that they might be called in to
a grand jury didn't you well I think I
was quite careful what I said after that
I may have said something to all these
people of that effect but I also
whenever anybody asked me any details I
said look I don't want you to be a
witness or I turn you into witness or
give you information that could get you
in trouble I just wouldn't talk how bad
lawyers didn't talk to people about if
all of these people let's leave out mrs.
curry for a minute Vernon Jordan said
blumenthal John Podesta Harold Ickes
Erskine Bowles Harry Thomason after the
story broke after Judge stars
involvement was known On January 21st
have said that you denied a sexual
relationship with them are you denying
that no and I'm going to tell you what I
meant by it I told you what I meant by
when they started this deposition you
told us now that you were being
careful but then it might have been
misleading is that correct it might have
been since we have seen this for year
forty million dollar investigation come
down to parsing the definition of sex I
think it might have been I I don't think
at the time but I thought that's what
this was gonna be about in fact and if
you remember the headlines at the time
even you mentioned that post story all
the headlines were and all the talking
with people who talked about this
including a lot who have been a quite
sympathetic to your operation said well
this is not really a story about sex
this is a story about subber nation of
perjury in these talking points and all
this other stuff so I what I was trying
to do was to to give them something they
could that would be true even if
misleading in the context of this
deposition and keep him out of trouble
and let's deal and deal with the what I
thought was the almost ludicrous
suggestion that I had heard someone to
lie or tried to suborn perjury in other
way oh it's clear from that excerpt I
think that in the hours and days
immediately following the release of the
Post story the president was struggling
with two competing concerns how to give
some explanation to the men and women
they worked with every day and work with
most closely without putting them in the
position of being grand jury witnesses
but he was not in any sense
seeking to tamper with them or to
obstruct the grand jury's investigation
putting aside for the moment our
strenuous disagreement both were the
factual underpinning of and the legal
conclusions that flow from the managers
analysis of these events I find it
difficult to figure out how it is that
they believe the president intended that
his statement to mr. Blumenthal are a
statement to mr. Podesta would involve
their conveying false information to the
grand jury or that he sought in some
fashion to send that message to the
grand jury when at the very moment that
those days were first subpoenaed he
asserted executive privilege to prevent
them from testifying before the grand
jury for someone who wanted mr.
Blumenthal to serve as the manners would
have it as his messenger of lies
that's strange behavior indeed now
there's an issue here that I don't
really want to get into at length and I
haven't heard the last two hours of
managers presentation don't know whether
they're gonna get into and that is the
manager brand was favorite issue
question of whether there was some
scheme to smear Monica Lewinsky early
middle or late other than to say that no
such plan ever existed I just want to
ask the managers this although I must
admit that for the first time in my life
I have heard Marlene Dietrich's name
used as a pejorative what was manager
Brian saying about Miss Lewinsky that
she was lying that she misled the
managers that because her testimony
helped the president they were now going
to attack her character and her
integrity I don't know how many of you
seen witness for the prosecution
either before or after mr. Bryant used
that example but ask yourselves what was
he saying what was he doing
ladies and gentlemen the Senate I don't
know there's a market for used pillars
but they're all lying in the dust
it's difficult for me as a lawyer as an
advocate for my client to speak to this
body about lofty constitutional
principles without seeming merely to
engage and empty rhetoric but I'd like
to think I guess that if there were ever
a forum in which I could venture into
that realm be excused for doing so
could be heard without the intervening
filter of skepticism that I fear too
often laws between lawyer and listener
this is the time and this is the moment
only once before in our nation's history
has any lawyer had the opportunity to
make a closing argument on behalf of the
president the United States and only
once before has the Senate ever had to
sit in judgment on the head of the
executive branch
we all must cast an eye to the past
looking over our shoulders to be sure
that we've learned the right lessons
from those who sat in this chamber
before us we also must look to future to
be sure that we leave the right lessons
to those who come after us we hope that
no one will ever have need of them but
if they should we owe them not only the
proper judgment for today but the proper
judgment for all time now you've heard
the managers tell you very early on in
these meetings that we've advanced a
quote so what defense that we're saying
that the president's conduct is really
nothing to be concerned about that we
should all simply go home and ignore
what he's done
not of course to choose a word that
would have been familiar to the framers
themselves is balderdash if you want to
see so what
look elsewhere so what if the framers
reserved impeachment and removal for
only those offenses that threatened the
state so what if the House Judiciary
Committee didn't quite do their
constitutional job if they took the
independent counsels referral and added
a few frills and then washed their hands
so what if the House approved articles
that wouldn't pass muster in any court
in the land so what if the managers have
been creating their own theories of
impeachment as they go along and so what
and so what and so what by contrast what
we offer is not so what but this aspect
the framers handed down to us as the
standard for moving the president asked
what impeachment and removal would mean
to our system of government in years to
come ask what you always asked in this
chamber what is best for the country
now the president wouldn't allow any of
us to say so what to so much as suggest
that he what he has done can simply be
forgotten he's asked for forgiveness
from his family and from the American
people and he's asked for the
opportunity to earn that their trust his
opening remarks manager hide question
whether this president can represent the
interest of our country in the world go
to Ireland and ask that question go to
Israel and Gaza knows that question or
if you doubt whether he should here at
home continue in office as the parent
whose child walks safer streets whether
men and women who go off the work in the
morning and put jobs
we are we are together I think weavers
of a constitutional fabric in which all
of us now are closed and generations
will be clothed from millennia to come
we cannot leave even the smallest flaw
in that fabric for if we do one day
someone will come along and pull a
thread and the floor will grow and it
will eat away at the fabric around it
and soon the entire cloth will begin to
unravel we must be as close to perfect
in what we do here today as women and
men are capable of being if there is
doubt about our course surely we must
take special care as we hold the fabric
of democracy in our hands so leave it as
we found it tightly woven strong
now before today I wrote down following
the rules say that the managers will
have the last word well the rules today
say the managers will have the last
paragraphs but that truly isn't so
because even when they are finished
theirs will not be the last voices you
hear yes one or more of them will now
rise and come to the podium and tell you
that they have the right of it and we
the wrong that our sense of what the
Constitution demands is not theirs and
should not be yours that is their
privilege but as each of them does come
before you for the final time and as you
listen to them I know that you will hear
not their eloquence as grand as it may
be not the pointed jobs of manager
hutchinson or the stand Torian tones of
manager rogen nor the homespun homilies
of knowledge of gram nor the grave
expectations of manager hard-put voices
of greater eloquence than any of us can
muster the voices of Madison Hamilton
and the others who met in Philadelphia
two hundred and twelve years ago and the
voices of the generations since and the
voices of the American people now and
the voices of generations to come these
out the voices of mere advocates must be
our dawn
it's been an honor for all of us to
appear before you in these last weeks on
behalf of the President and now our last
words to you which of the words I'd be
game began with William Jefferson
Clinton is not guilty of the charges
that have been brought against him he
did not commit perjury he did not commit
obstruction of justice
he must not he will move from all of us
thank you very much the chair recognizes
the majority I ask consent that we take
a 15-minute recess without objection
it's so ordered
as the Senate takes this